We define an RNN cell that basically
takes in the input and the working
memory from the previous step,
concatenate them and with a forward
neural network with a tangent hyperbolic
activation returns the HT or the hidden
state for the next step. So this is the
RNN cell with this input and output. So
we discussed that this hidden state is
more like a shortterm memory and there
are many nonlinear repeated weight
multiplication on its way that makes the
back propagation really difficult. One
idea here is to keep another state that
is like the cell state that acts like a
conveyor belt does not have any repeated
nonlinear overrides
uh and multiplication like the other
one. So the cell state is like the
longterm memory. So CT minus one will
have some addition from the input data
and the shortterm memory. Let's just for
now call it delta at time t updates the
ct minus one with this addition and that
gives us ct. This allows the information
and gradients to flow largely unchange
as there are no weights directly
modifying the ma main pathway. But if we
think of long-term memory like a limited
amount of memory that we want to use
wisely in a way that complements the
short-term memory or the the hidden
state, we want another gate that
basically forgets the past and updates
it with the addition here. So think of
that like a valve here that we can
control its angle. the same information
comes but we reduces that to allow for
an addition or an update. So this is
forgetting and this is addition. Okay.
So we want to engineer an architecture
that does this and allows for this
direct line of memory while allowing for
an update on the working memory or the
short short-term memory. Let's do that.
So let's replace let's replace this
valve with a function that is changing
between zero and one and it's like
basically an app that allows the
information to either completely flow or
completely stop at something in between.
And this is we know this is a we have a
function like that we call it sigmoid
that we will show with with sigma. So we
want the sigmoid function to multiply
here right and this is a it inputs the
htus one and xt and of course it will
have a set of weights for uh not uh
making the picture very busy I'm going
to remove this weights and I assume that
you guys know before any of this
activations any of these activations I'm
going to have a rate like this and we
will see that in the code. So now let's
focus on how to update the uh long-term
memory. So again we want to uh bring the
information here and this information
will go through a neural network a feed
for a neural network and it will give us
another state right. So it will be a fit
for a neural network with a tangent
hyperbolic and that will be the the new
state that we want to add to the uh to
the cell state. Let's call it CT hat or
that delta here. But we should be
careful also gate this. We want to put a
valve here too. And the valve also will
be a sigmoid. The flow is also gated
here. What else? Um here we can complete
the updates here. It's a bit more nuance
because we want to use this long-term
memory, right? And also of course this
new information. So basically here I'm I
I want to think about something here
that give us the input uh of XT and HD
minus one. use that input and also use
this long-term memory to make an update
and give us the HD that of course we can
use for let's say predicting Y here.
Okay, so let's do that. I'm not going to
make another neural network here that
use tangent hyperbolic, right? I already
did this here and this information goes
inside with this addition. So I'm going
to just use this uh from here. We are
not going to do this again. I just want
to put a gate from here. So just want to
use a gate to control this information
which comes from here. Right? So tangent
hyperbolic again that calculates the
state and it's gated by the input and
then we send this for the new HD. So if
I want to write this in equation, you
can think of this part here first which
takes in the inputs and there is a
normal network with a sigmoid that
scales the forgetting here. Right? So
let's write this down. If I call this
f_t, f_t will be sigma some neural
network takes in concatenation of hg
minus1 and xt and maybe some bias. Now
let's go to the next step that writes to
the memory here. And of course we have a
scaling of that writing that controls
the amount that we are writing. So if I
call this IT that's CT we will have it.
So this is the input gate that chooses
the amount of the candidate to be added
and of course the candidate before that
which is a tangent h some wc again the
concatenation and some bias. So then
after the applying the gate we have the
addition here. So let's write this down
which gives the CT right. So this is the
final CT which is of course the gate
that we applied element wise on CT minus
one and then the addition of the gated
candidate right again element wise so
everything is element wise okay great so
let's go back here we want to output the
new hidden state let's write this down
maybe I I I'm going to call the gate
here OT so we have a gate okay and then
HT will be the element wise tangent
hyperbolic of CT. That's how we build
LSTM. So as you saw LSTM first is
relying on this two activation function
the sigmoid that acts like a controller
that controls the amount of flow and
squashes the input into this range of 0
to one. You can interpret the output
like a percentage on how much
information to let through like that
ball valve that I initially showed. And
then the next uh activation function
just like what we had in RNN it's the
content shaper. So this helps to
regulate the values that is flowing
through the network keeps the content
bounded and of course centered around
zero. So assume that the forgetting gate
is basically not blocking anything and
it's like close to one value and
actually that's a good value to start
the training because this allowed the
information to flow and the gradient can
have long range values. So as you see
LSTM architecture is a bit complex. Uh
later there was another uh architecture
that was introduced that is known as GRU
or gated recurrent unit that simplifies
this cell here and it merges the cell
state and the hidden state again and it
also merges the forgetting and the input
gates. So there's like two valves here
that in GRU they will be merged. But in
GRU there will be a a different gate
that is known as resetting gate and it
controls how much of the previous hidden
state is considered when calculating the
candidate. So for example if RT like I
said the reset gate is near zero it
basically forgets all of the previous
hidden state or ignores it. and this way
resets and treat the current input XT as
the start of a new relevant sequence. So
I'm going to skip GRU here. But of
course it's a very useful architecture
with fewer parameters. So it basically
it has two gates versus the three gates
here in the LSTM. It has only two gates
the RT and the measured FNI. Okay. So
with that we can go ahead and code LSTM.